we're in culpeper virginia
at this building which ones belong to
the feds
on the surface the purpose was they
stored gold here four billion dollars
worth of gold currency to be exact but
that was just on the surface the real
purpose of it was sort of an
anti-nuclear contingency program during
the cold war if the big bomb went off
they would move the president here but
that's all in the past now they have
something completely different
film yes we have the classics here we
have casablanca and we have the maltese
falcon we have frankenstein
we also have
gili and we have all the adam sandler
movies this building is now the library
of congress's packard campus its goal is
to ensure the survival and conservation
of our nation's films and over 144 000
of the most precious of these is under
the care of george williams
but first let's explore the building
there is a suite
where our technicians do nothing but
repair films we have specialized rooms
for printing for film processing data
cine transfer cylinder recordings
special suites for doing two inch video
tapes one inch videotapes three quarter
inch videotape you name it we play it
all these rooms exist because the
packard campus is about restoration and
preservation
and those first early pieces they were
made on nitrate and that's what george
is in charge of
he's head of the nitrate vaults
the oldest and most dangerous of all the
film bases
we have 124 nitrate film vaults they're
very austere looking like a high
security prison
and they're very thick walled designed
to protect us
from the films and the films from each
other because nitrate film has the basic
same chemical compound as gunpowder and
is highly flammable
a nitrate fire is like nothing you have
ever seen
because it's almost like a controlled
explosion it burns with a bright orange
yellow flame and it looks like a rocket
engine
we have negatives in our vaults that are
over 100 years old
things come into us that have been in
barns and warehouses and people's attics
and basements and i've been able to be
involved in the restoration of several
films that otherwise in the outside
world would have no
monetary value but their historical
value is immense
[Music]
my interest has always been in early
film
and i am getting a chance to work with
one of the largest and most unique
collections of early film in the world
i think i'm here for a reason
i think my purpose
is to make sure that
we remember
to know what we had
and what we looked like and what we did
and film is one of the absolute best
ways of doing that
[Music]
you